what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and while the season finale of one
division showed us that
having fun isn't hard if you've got a
library card it also showed us white
vision checking out of the westview
public library
at high speeds one of the smartest
beings on the planet and yet still
somehow doesn't know how to use a door
which is
kind of weird i will push if i want to
punch
i hate doors with the restoration of
white vision's memories by hex vision
marvel studios is obviously setting up
white vision for another appearance in a
future mcu
project but the question remains uh
which one marvel
like where the hell are we gonna see
tyler mayonnaise's pasty white version
of a vision
next huh well being the self-proclaimed
marvel scientist that i am
you already know that i got me a wild
theory on deck based on what we know
it's just one of many theories that i
have in my weird brain of where white
vision could have gone
and it's one that has to do with the
upcoming armor wars disney plus show
starring don cheadle because frankly
boom we are looking for this
now we don't know a whole lot about
marvel studios's upcoming armor wars
project
quite yet but we do know that it will
most likely take elements from the
original armor wars storyline from the
comics that followed tony stark
giving an iron ass whooping to all of
the nosy nefarious nerds
trying to replicate all of his
technology and just generally steal
anthony edwards entire flow like just
trying to jack his whole
also i call tony stark anthony edward
sometimes because we close
and you know now that tony stark is gone
the power hungry fingers of the mcu
are so ready to do just that and mcu
roadie
aka the black bestie ain't about all
that plagiarism son
not at all i mean ever since dawn
shields first appearance as rhodey at
the beginning of iron man 2
everybody been out here trying to be
like the man anthony edward but they
can't or at least they couldn't while
tony stark was alive because
he was definitely on high alert for any
iron copycats you know ever since justin
hammer decided to dance with ivan vanko
and create all those hammer drones that
almost killed everybody at that expo but
now that tony stark is gone the race to
break down his suits and all of his
technological achievements is back on
like donkey kong
with organizations and likely even
governments across the globe attempting
to replicate tony's iron legacy for
their own ends
but what does an armor war scenario have
to do with white vision well we of
course can find that answer
at our local public library the westview
public library to be specific because
when hex vision is trying to convince
white vision to let him touch himself
he specifically says as a carbon-based
synthesis
your memory storage is not so easily
white before unlocking all of those core
memories that sword was keeping from
their weaponized white vision
and why is this significant because
restoring white vision's memories not
only could have brought
visions memories back but also ultron's
original operational system
within vision's body because let's not
forget that bruce banner said in
avengers infinity war that
vision is made up of a complex construct
of overlaids that came from
him tony stark jarvis the mind stone and
of course
ultron but when vision was repurposed by
tony and bruce
ultron's consciousness matrix was
suppressed in favor
of jarvis's programming and if you look
back at age of ultron you can see that a
full
86 of ultron's matrix was uploaded to
vision before steve rogers suggested
that you know
ultron unplug and come outside and play
for a little bit so if hex vision is
correct and vision's memory storages
aren't so easily wiped then it's very
possible that hex vision
fully unlocked white vision accidentally
including
ultron's original uploaded programming
which could very well be
just as bad as it sounds and this is
where armor wars comes in because if
roadie is supposedly going around the
globe
taking down phony starks with their own
iron man tech
then hmm a world attempting to encase
itself in a suit of armor
this sure sounds a whole lot like what
tony stark was trying to do with the
iron legion program
what we needed was a pseudo armor around
the world remember that
hmm and it also sounds like ultron's
original programming directive
piece of our time that's right everybody
we could very much see
white vision being the very force
spreading the secrets of tony stark
suits
to the world in an attempt to continue
that main world peace mission of all
three of his creators but this time
in his own way not the way ultron wanted
not the way tony and bruce wanted but
the way
he wants and the way he deems the most
efficient now that he is 100
a free elf with 100 of his memories but
before i continue i just want to give a
quick shout out and thanks to skillshare
for sponsoring this video skillshare is
an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
curious creative folks
skillshare lets you explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity skillshare offers classes
designed for real life like learning bro
with short classes that fit any schedule
and each class is a combination of video
lessons and a class project
and they have topics that new rockstars
fans will enjoy like animation
film music and freelancing one of their
classes that sounds really fun and
delightfully specific
is how to speak confidently on camera a
guide for content creators taught by
nathaniel drew
now i'm pretty confident on camera
myself but i'm always looking for new
tricks and techniques in this
class focuses on how to feel more
authentic and real on camera because
that's really important
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning that there are no ads and
they're always launching new premium
classes so that you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and it's less than ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription which
is pretty great on the wallet i gotta
say
and the first 1 000 of my subscribers to
click on the link in the description
will get a free trial of the premium
membership so that you can explore
your creativity skillshare let's get
creative shall we
now one of the main reasons why i
believe x vision could have accidentally
awakened
ultron's influence within white vision's
body is because one of the first images
we see during white vision's memory
recall
are pictures of tony stark bruce banner
and wanda maximoff the three most
important people
envisions life but with all of these
images is this picture right here of
vision himself which got me thinking how
the hell did vision even get this
picture in his memory like why does he
have
that image of himself in his memory
storages which then got me asking wait a
minute
why is there a picture of a hulk buster
there vision wasn't even alive to see
tony and bruce's fight
in south africa in age of ultron so like
why is this
among vision's memories which then
caused me to realize that all of these
pictures
could have easily been captured from the
perspective of ultron
whether from a potential ultron century
in the area or
the main ultron himself because that
picture of vision in the forest at the
end of age of ultron was from a moment
that only he and the last ultron bot
shared you know before he mysteriously
blasted that last ultron bot
off screen like nobody else was around
for that moment and yes
this is a memory of visions and could be
symbolic of that
but my question is why take that moment
from the perspective of vision
and not the last ultron bot which is
what a
vision would have been recording and
remembering from his point of view this
could be symbolic of ultron's
perspective
being jolted alive within vision once
more which could inspire him to attempt
his own
take on tony and ultron's peace in our
time dream
by essentially becoming the armor broker
of the mcu this is the most logical step
for the world's most logical being in my
opinion it's the perfect meshing of the
visions of all three of his dads
into a new vision for humanity all of
his own but this could also mean that
vision could have potentially saved
ultron
during that moment in the forest at the
end of age of ultron and stored him
somewhere within himself you know
because you can't really have a memory
image of yourself unless you're looking
at yourself in the mirror so
this is obviously taken from the
perspective of ultron who could be
living inside a vision because never
forget the vision was straight up with
the avengers from the jump when he said
i don't want to kill ultron he's unique
and he's in pain this all being said i
really do believe that it is possible
that white vision shot out of the west
view public library with 110
of his memories restored and could end
up being the very force that releases
papa tony stark's
secret iron man formula to all of the
planktons of the world
victory my name is sending rody on a
quest to stop this white vision and
hopefully
readjust his programming and most likely
with the help of one
bruce banner as he is the only one of
fission's science bro dads
that hasn't supposedly been killed by an
infinity stone or possibly with the help
of one
riri williams and with the iron heart
series in the works a roadie reread team
up in armor wars would be a dope way to
introduce audiences
to just how technologically capable the
mcu's future iron lady can be
as she runs i.t support for the war
machine but i've said my nerd words long
enough what do you guys think where do
you guys think that we'll see
white vision next sound off in the
comment section below but yes thank you
guys so much for watching this video and
feel free to follow me on social media
at mastertainment so you can follow all
the weird that i type on twitter
because i type a lot of weird
but most importantly follow new rock
stars wherever we are especially on
youtube and make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload a video
okay
do it let's do it thanks again for
watching and stay safe i love you guys
seriously i love you
[Music]
you